بدأ رجلان تداول البيتكوين في
اليوم نفسه. قضى أحدهما 12 ساعة يوميًا
يحدّق في الشموع، يطارد كل
اندفاع أخضر صغير. الليلة الماضية، فخ واحد فقط من
الحيتان صفّى كل مدخراته. أمّا
الرجل الآخر، فتناول العشاء مع عائلته،
ونام بهدوء، واستيقظ على
ربح قدره 5,000 دولار. الفرق لم يكن
حظًا. كان النظام. أحدهما كان
الصيّاد، والآخر كان المدافع. معظم
المتداولين يفشلون لأنهم يلعبون
لعبة الحيتان. يشترون عندما يُقال لهم
أن يشتروا، لكن الحيتان تنصب الفخاخ
وأنت الفريسة. Trap Defence BTC
يغيّر اللعبة من خلال جعل
غير المرئي مرئيًا. محركنا يكتشف
التلاعب المؤسسي قبل أن
يضرب حساباتك. نمنحك المهارة
النهائية في التداول، الانضباط للبقاء
آمنًا حتى تكون الاحتمالات لصالحك.
إنها دفاع عالي الدقة لسوق عالي
المخاطر. واليوم يمكنك تجهيز نفسك
بدون أي تكلفة. انضم الآن إلى
Defenders Academy واحصل على
النسخة المصغّرة من Trap Score
مجانًا. بدون بطاقة، بدون تعقيد، فقط
الحقيقة الخام للسوق. توقّف عن كونك
الفريسة، وكن أنت المدافع. اضغط أدناه
لتشغيل البوت والحصول على وصولك
المجاني الآن.